[Musique]
le conseil départemental des jeunes élit
son nouveau président ils sont huit
candidats en lice à présenter leur
programme pour cette nouvelle mandature
les résultats sont donnés et ce sera
victor perrigault du collège de
montgaillard qui présidera cette
assemblée pour l'année 2017 2018 gros
projets ce sont les projets sur l'eau
j'aimerais faire un projet sur l'eau et
visiter les usines hydrauliques la mise
en bouteille d eau de la réunion ensuite
j'aimerais faire une action sur les
talents des jeunes réunionnais car on a
trop tendance est exposée la face
négatif des jeunes
donc j'aimerais montrer la face positive
des jeunes il y a une action sur la
discrimination avec des minimes et des
expositions photographiques pour
sensibiliser les jeunes nous comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que j'aimerais
travailler sur l'homophobie et la
misogynie et ensuite ma dernière action
c'est de mettre en valeur les atouts de
la réunion mélissa grondin et la
première vice présidente et hugo pisino
le deuxième vice président
la passation de présidence et pleine
d'émotion l'occasion de faire le bilan
de l'ancienne mandature riche en
événements comme grandes actions jeu
prénommé peut-être l'action sur la
sécurité routière notamment sur la
pratique des deux roues l'action avec
les personnes en situation d'handicap
mais aussi l'action à la spa je pense
que c'est les trois axes qui n'ont plus
marqué
créé en 1989 le conseil départemental
des jeunes a pour vocation d'inciter les
collégiens réunionnais à s'impliquer
dans l'action politique et créer un
espace de dialogue en écoutant ses
candidats présenter leur candidature
leurs projets on se rend compte qu'ils
sont vraiment engagés et qui a un niveau
qui monte qui monte
donc ça fait plaisir parce que ce sont
les citoyens de demain engagés qui ont
pris conscience que
dès leur plus jeune âge ils ont besoin
de s'exprimer de s'engager et de porter
des responsabilités
cette élection a été aussi l'occasion de
présenter une nouvelle instance le
comité départemental des anciens cdj une
façon de montrer que l'engagement de ces
jeunes ne s'arrête pas à un mandat
[Musique]